hallo liebe userinnen willkommen zu
einem heute live stream zur großen klima
demo heute in glasgow mit frei dies
verfügte die dazu aufgerufen hatten wie
immer postet uns eure fragen eure
kommentare oder mailt sie uns ich
spreche gleich mit unserem
korrespondenten dort davor schauen wir
uns aber noch ein paar bilder an wie es
heute nachmittag gelaufen ist
tausende sind da auf die straße gegangen
freude ist for future haben wie gesagt
dazu aufgerufen kreta team berg war
dabei viele andere aktivistinnen auch
und umweltverbände sie alle kritisieren
dass die regierungen zu viel versprechen
aber zu wenig tun und letztlich noch zu
wenig passiert
und ein kollege andreas stamm ist da
seit heute nachmittag wir haben sogar
schon mal miteinander gesprochen und 15
uhr da ging es los wie ist es jetzt
gerade ich sehe sind immer noch leute da
ja es hat sich ein bisschen gelehrt
greta turmberg hat ja vor so einer
halben stunde gesprochen und das war ja
sozusagen der auftritt auf den hier die
klimaaktivisten und klimaaktivisten
gewartet haben sie ist diejenige die
freude des futures irgendwie gegründet
hat und das ganze ins rollen gebracht
hat und heute war eben diese erste große
demo morgen gibt's noch eine und sie hat
ziemlich klaren standpunkt bezogen dass
das was die politiker und die staats-
regierungschefs machen ist eigentlich
nur noch gewäsch greenwashing das
braucht man nicht mehr die leute die
protestbewegungen steht außen vor das
waren schon ziemlich harte worte
aufseher kapitalismus kritisch und das
hat hier viele begeistert aber zeigt
halt eben dass die diskrepanz zwischen
den politikern vielleicht zwischen den
entscheidungsträgern und kopf 26 und den
menschen hier auf der straße den
demonstranten den protestierenden
doch deutlich auseinander geht und kopf
26 ist vielleicht da einen tipping point
einen entscheiden weg für diese beiden
bewegungen also das hat sich nicht hier
wirklich gut integriert was konkret
werfen die protestierenden von kork 26
den den regierenden vor was sind die
genauen kritikpunkte meine wir kennen
sie ja basically aber was genau wird da
formuliert auch in den verschiedenen
reden
ich glaube die frage würde ich
weitergeben ich habe zwar gäste zwei
menschen aus deutschland die den weg
hierher gefunden haben junge menschen
das einmal alex eigentlich aus
rüsselsheim jetzt in brighton im schönen
vereinigten königreich zu hause und
philipp aus münchen jetzt in brüssel
also durchaus kosmopoliten was ist was
wirft er den politikern vor könnt ihr
das kurz und knackig zusammen weiß was
läuft schief die auf kopf 26 ich würde
sagen es ist nicht nur hier bei der kopf
26 sondern schon die letzten jahrzehnte
dass was schief läuft die politikerinnen
verteidigen die profite der privaten
konzerne sind kapitalistischen staaten
das ist das hauptziel es geht ist nicht
vereinbar mit klimaschutz das heißt sie
kommen sehr in bedrängnis die
klimaschutzziele zu erfüllen eigentlich
scheitert ist komplett und das merken
die leute und spiegelt unser stimmung
wieder deswegen auch die
antikapitalistische stimmung die sich
schon am eingang jetzt erwähnt haben
alex muss dazu ja ich bin zu und auch
einfach dass ich viel zu wenig tut ich
bin seit etwa fünf jahren aktiv und es
hat mich wirklich nicht viel bewegt und
ich bin einfach hier um zu zeigen dass
die welt zuschaut und
das
1,5 grad glaube roaming
ein sehr wichtiger tage da sind wenn wir
das ziel
warum ist das deutsche wort
über wisse das wort das ziel
überschreiten dankeschön wird alles viel
viel schlimmer und wer mehr dieses jahr
schon überschwemmung und brände und
alles gesehen also ist zeit zu handeln
das zumindest sagen ja die politiker es
ist 14 12 aber wie gesagt die diskrepanz
ist groß augen uns auch sagen es sind
auch viele hier die sagen wir geben die
hoffnung nicht auf und wir protestieren
weiter
wir haben einen guten von greta
tannenberg auch isoliert und wollen uns
den einmal anhören was die gute frau zu
sagen hatte
[Applaus]
duathlon celebration of business as
usual
blablabla
vertrauen in der green devils
und promise ist
dennoch leicht
[Musik]
den berg hat gesagt dass das die
klimakonferenz war ich übersetze ich
eben kurz für die die englisch nicht so
oft hören dass die konferenz eine der
exklusivsten oder ausschließen ssten war
die sie je gesehen hat das ist ein
zweiwöchiges greenwashing festival war
also dass man sagt man plant und hat
tolle ideen die auch nach grüner politik
und ökologische politik klingen ist aber
nicht sind dass die leute die da vor ort
sind die nase voll haben vom blabla von
diesem greenwashing und dass diejenigen
die am meisten betroffen sind und in den
am schwersten betroffenen regionen leben
wieder nicht gehört worden seien und die
zukünftigen generationen nicht
berücksichtigt wurden die zukünftigen
generationen ertrinken hat sie gesagt
wir haben denn die leute vor ort
reagiert als kreta teamwork gesprochen
hat was war da für eine stimmung
[Musik]
das war schon
natürlich ist dass die ikone dieser
bewegung auch sie betätigt gefeiert wie
ein popstar das wäre ein bisschen
übertrieben wenn das sieht dann noch ein
bisschen anders aus aber natürlich hat
jeder darauf gewartet das war ihre
einzige oder ist ihre einzige rede
gewesen öffentlich in diesem forum auf
dem kopf 26 will sie ja gar nicht mehr
sprechen und ich glaube sie hat den
punkt schon gut getroffen habt aber nur
auf der einen seite denn man muss sagen
ich habe mit vielen hier werden des
demonstrationszugs gesprochen einfach
mal rein gefragt da waren auch viele
ältere dabei mütter und die natürlich
vielleicht nicht ganz so krass das sehen
die doch noch hoffnung haben und die
glauben dass man doch noch was bewegen
kann mit protest und dass man die
politiker vielleicht doch noch ein
bisschen schubsen kann lg hat heute
gesprochen ist einer der klima-
aktivisten der ersten stunde zumindest
aus dem politischen establishment der
ehemalige us-vizepräsident und er sagt
er spürt dass es einen tipping point
gegeben hat dass die politik wirklich
langsam aufwacht dann würde man hier
natürlich wieder kontern und sagen das
ist gelaber das kommt viel zu spät und
das passt einfach nicht aber das ist nah
da tut sich ein graben auf und ich
glaube da würde ich einmal noch die
frage an unsere beiden gäste stellen
glaubt ihr denn dass sich
das nicht mehr lohnt einfach nur
friedlich und freundlich und wie hier
mit so einem großen karneval sondern
muss man sich radikalisieren in welcher
form auch immer ohne da jetzt irgendwie
was produzieren zu wollen oder
reicht das einfach was passiert passiert
also ehrlich ein radikales natürlich
schweres wort ich bin der meinung dass
das quasi peaceful friedliche proteste
extrem wichtig sind und dass hier was
hier passiert schon viel bewirken wird
ich bin der meinung das ist vielleicht
das ist vielleicht extremer werden wird
uns weiter werden muss ich bin gegen
gewalt deswegen jetzt nicht
gewalttätige muss ja nicht unbedingt
gewalt sein radikal aber trotzdem ein
bisschen radikaler vielleicht ein
bisschen mit mehr mit mehr schmiss oder
reich dass ihr ich glaube es braucht
eine andere strategie oder eine
erweiterung der strategie dass wir bis
jetzt hatten war eine hauptsächliche
jugendbewegung die demonstriert wie
heute was unglaublich wichtig ist weil
die ideologischen pfeiler haben sich
verschoben da durch das thema ist auf
dem tableau und die politikerin unter
zugzwang aber es passiert nichts sehen
wir seit jahren und jahrzehnten
und ich glaube wir brauchen jetzt eine
erweiterung der strategie und müssen die
jugendbewegungen von klima streiks aus
der schule und der uni verbinden mit der
arbeiterinnenbewegung den gewerkschaften
und mögliche streiks in den betrieben
auf großer fläche organisieren jetzt
wird es natürlich schon extrem aber wenn
das der weg ist aber gewalt aber
gewaltfreie auf jeden fall das sollte
auf jeden fall gewaltfrei aber es geht
hier um die ökonomische macht also es
ist ja nicht so dass die politikerin
nicht wissen was zu tun wäre aber es ist
im konflikt mit den interesse der
wirtschaft und der politik die privaten
interessen der privaten provinzen zu
verteidigen das schneidet sich haben wir
ganz gut gesehen bei hambacher forst
2018 regt jetzt geht's mit den zuschlag
ins detail aber ich glaube die message
ist klar also muss es muss ein schritt
angezogen werden und es muss auch sagen
wir mal es muss ein bisschen mehr weh
tun ohne dass es gewalttätig werde ich
glaube dass das kann man sagen das kann
man zusammenfassen
die stimmung also wie niemand ruft zur
gewalt auf nein davon bin ich
ehrlicherweise auch nicht ausgesagt
ausgegangen angesichts der bilder wie
haben einen kommentar von jeffrey goerke
von facebook und er sand sehr gut da
sich die jugend um ihre zukunft gedanken
macht besser als meine generation damals
ich würde ganz gerne noch mal die frage
zurück spielen an deine beiden gäste
andreas also du hast gesagt er ist
schwingt kapitalismuskritik mit jetzt
haben wir von arbeiterinnen streiks
gehört du sagst gerade es wird extrem
können die beiden nochmal genauer sagen
worin ihre kapitalismuskritik besteht
kommt noch mal die frage aus mainz
worin besteht denn jetzt die
kapitalismuskritik könnte es so auf den
punkt bringen was was ist noch mal ein
kurzer blick was ist eure kritik an
diesem system
kapitalismus steht für mehr profite und
mehr profite heißt wenn man sich
anschaut wo die emissionen her kommen
auch mehr emissionen es gibt keine
weniger emissionen und mehr profite das
heißt man muss dieses system der
privaten profite abschaffen wir brauchen
öffentliches eigentum unter
demokratischer kontrolle der gesamten
bevölkerung und das sehen wir sehr gut
am öffentlichen verkehrssystem die öffis
in glasgow sind unglaublich schlecht
weil sie nicht es sind sondern sind
sieben private busunternehmen wo es zwei
oder drei verschiedene gibt es
funktioniert nicht es ist teurer
geplante sachen die öffentlich verwaltet
werden funktionieren besser sind
günstiger und hier können wir priorität
priorisieren ob wir sachen wollen die
grünen sind die grüne jobs schaffen oder
fossile sachen die weiterhin für erdöl
kohle usw das muss demokratisch
entschieden werden und
da sind wir alle gefragt und wenn die
beschäftigten in den fossilen industrien
in der autoindustrie sagen wir wollen
eure sachen nicht mehr produzieren wir
wollen grüne jobs und wir blockieren die
arbeit wir pumpen blockieren eure
profite bis wir dieses ziel erreichen
dann haben wir unglaubliche macht und
das ist das ziel der jugendbewegung mit
der arbeiterinnenbewegung zu verknüpfen
und ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig dass
sich die jugendlichen aber auch die
beschäftigten organisieren zusammen in
den gewerkschaften
und der sozialistischen gruppe beitreten
in deutschland werde die sozialistische
alternative
international heißen wir international
socialist alternativ und es wird ein
langer weg doch werden aber ich glaube
die mehrheit ist auch um zur seite und
behörden haben sie eigentlich wissen
alle die hier sind haben extrem viel
hoffnung es ist nicht dass die leute
hier die hoffnung aufgegeben haben hab
also klimaschutz in die betriebe ist das
wäre mal siehst du das ähnlich alex
ja ja doch eigentlich sehe schon ähnlich
einfach das
unendliches wachstum auf einem planeten
wie hier nicht möglich ist und was im
endeffekt dann bedeuten wird dass es
entweder kapitalismus oder menschenleben
und sein wird ich mein ich weiß nicht
was die alternative wäre und ich ganz
ehrlich sein aber wir wissen
mittlerweile oder wir sehen das ist so
in unserem system nicht funktioniert
also worauf ich auf jeden fall heiligen
könnte ist dass der kapitalismus ein
schwieriges konstrukt ist wenn es um
klimaschutz geht wie man dann damit
verfährt und ob es alternativen gibt mir
die aussehen ich meine klar das ist aber
vielleicht auch nicht die aufgabe von
kopf 26 da müssen noch viele viele viele
gedanken und dinge passieren
wahrscheinlich ja wir sind interessant
ist wie hier die systeme fragen unserer
zeit und auch der vergangenheit
gesprochen haben tatsächlich spreche ich
nachher mit einem wirtschafts und
nachhaltigkeits forscher über das
richtige in anführungszeichen
wirtschaften oder beziehungsweise
nachhaltig ist schafften und auch was
das für die reichen und die superreichen
bedeutet das kommt auch vor ich wollte
ich nur eine sache fragen andreas das
war jetzt ja erst mal nur der erste tag
der der demonstration wie geht es jetzt
weiter es kommt ja morgen für morgen
sind ja noch viel mehr leute erwartet
und was versprechen sie sich davon
das war der der kleine aufgalopp
eigentlich nur also 10.000 leute
geschätzt ich weiß ich habe noch keine
offizielle zahl der polizei gehört aber
das kann man wohl von ausgehen und
morgen soll es in glasgow 50 vielleicht
100.000 demonstrierende geben das ist
dann die ganz große weltweite initiative
es könnte so die veranstalter in bis zu
200 städten überall auf dem globus zu
protesten und zu demonstranten
demonstrationen kommen das ist ebenso
mal der ganz große busch sind diese
beiden tage die dann morgen im samstag
dann in diesem höhepunkt kombinieren
indem man doch noch einmal druck machen
will denn wie man konferenz läuft weiter
das letzte wort ist noch nicht
gesprochen und es gilt ja auch immer das
mantra von jedes zehntel grad jede
kleine verbesserung zählt und ich glaube
das ist das ziel diesen aus sicht der
aktivisten aktivistin sehr lahmen lahmen
ersten erst die erste woche der sehr
lahme erste woche vielleicht dann doch
noch ein bisschen ein bisschen in
schwung zu bringen das dann vielleicht
mehr rauskommen zumindest mehr im sinne
von dem was hier gefordert wird
geht der gipfel ja noch weiter es ist ja
noch eine ganze woche vor uns und da
wollte ich nicht fragen was steht da an
tagesordnungspunkten neben den
verschiedenen verhandlungen in den
verschiedenen bereichen noch auf dem
programm
es geht natürlich im endeffekt um die
schlusserklärung und um und da wird
natürlich gerungen denn das was die
straße regierungschef zum beispiel in
den ersten beiden tagen vorgegeben haben
ist ja nur die blaupause und hinter den
kulissen wird dann natürlich verhandelt
da sitzen die vertreter von 190 staaten
die ganz mächtigen aber auch die ganz
kleinen die stark betroffenen und die
die vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr
zeit haben und die kniffeln da und da
ist noch eine menge bewegung drin und
das ist wird diese zweite woche prägen
die bis nächsten freitag geht man hofft
ist manchmal geht es ja auch in die
verlängerung wie in paris wo man lange
lange rum tüftelt und rum werkelte also
man muss sagen die weichenstellungen
sieht nicht wirklich nach einem großen
durchbruch auch vielleicht konnte man
das auch nicht erwarten die
weltpolitische lage hat das vielleicht
nicht zugelassen aber es ist noch eine
woche zeit und da wird noch viel
verhandelt und damit noch viel
diplomatie betrieben und da kann man
vielleicht dann bis freitag noch einiges
mehr für den klimaschutz rausholen vor
allen dingen in dem sinne wie das hier
die aktivisten und aktivistinnen bei
dieser demonstration verstehen vielen
dank andreas stamm wir hören und
sprechen uns vermutlich noch ein paar
mal mehr alles gute nach glasgow
wir haben jetzt noch eine userin die
kommentiert hat auf facebook die gesagt
hat alles schön und gut dann sollten
diese aktivistinnen auch detailgetreu
erklären wie sie die immensen kosten
stemmen wollen ohne dass jeder einzelne
massive geldeinbußen hat darüber
sprechen wir tatsächlich gleich mit
professor jakob hörisch eure fragen und
kommentare dazu fragen an einen
nachhaltigkeits forscher bitte in die
kommentare oder per mail
jetzt wollen wir weiter sehen wir haben
nämlich tatsächlich auf diesem gipfel
auch commitments gehört verschiedene
staaten und regierungen haben sich
zusammengesetzt haben sich tatsächlich
beispielsweise gegen die abholzung und
gegen das abbrennen von wäldern und
regenwäldern ausgesprochen und haben
sich tatsächlich bei einem initiative
auch auf eine jahreszahl geeinigt und
welche anderen ziele noch dabei
herausgekommen sind welche
absichtserklärungen vor allem das
schauen wir uns jetzt in einem beitrag
an
105 länder wollen ihre emissionen von
methan bis 2030 reduzieren um 30 prozent
im vergleich zu 2020 bisher sind die
beteiligten staaten für 40 prozent des
globalen methan ausstoßes verantwortlich
190 staaten haben sich dazu bereit
erklärt in den 2030er jahren aus der
kohle auszusteigen dazu gehört auch
deutschland
weltweit soll der kohleausstieg dann in
den 2000 40er jahren gelingen
100 milliarden us dollar so viel geld
haben die industriestaaten versprochen
entwicklungsländern für den klimaschutz
zur verfügung zu stellen doch das
erfüllen sie bisher nicht in glasgow
haben mehrere länder neue zusagen
gemacht
bis 2030 wollen 110 staaten den verlust
der wälder stoppen dazu gehören
brasilien indonesien und die
demokratische republik kongo sie und die
weiteren beteiligten länder
repräsentieren 85 prozent der waldfläche
weltweit
und ich spreche als mit professor jakob
hörisch von der leuphana universität in
lüneburg
hallo herr höre herzlich willkommen
schön dass sie es einrichten konnten
und herzliche grüße aus lüneburg
dankeschön wir haben jetzt ja schon
einiges gehört ein bisschen
kapitalismuskritik aktivismus aber auch
greenwashing und da wollte ich sie
fragen der aspekt greenwashing wie sehen
sie das und passt das zu dieser
klimakonferenz oder sehen sie es ganz
anders
also ich teile natürlich die kritik dass
noch deutlich mehr gemacht werden muss
das ist jetzt wirklich die zeit dafür
ist maßnahmen zu beschließen dieser
begriff des greenwashing sich gebe zu
wenn sie genau den herausgreifen dann tu
ich mir damit ein bisschen schwer was
meint greenwashing eigentlich dass man
vorgibt etwas zu tun obwohl man es gar
nicht tut das ist nicht das was ich
wahrnehme sondern ich nehme wahr dass er
die staatengemeinschaft etwas
beschlossen hat dass auch maßnahmen
ergriffen werden wir haben jetzt ein co2
preis in deutschland beispielsweise das
ist nicht nichts und ich glaube auch
dass wenig gut daran tun dann immer zu
sagen das ist gar nichts und das ist nur
greenwashing aber da bin ich dann wieder
voll bei gerät hat 100 das reicht hinten
und vorne nicht also ja wir müssen mehr
tun aber ich glaube so sozusagen diese
differenzierung die dürfen wir uns schon
erlauben es ist nicht so dass nichts
gemacht wird deswegen bin ich mit dem
green washing begriff nicht ganz
einverstanden und die maßnahmen die
beschlossen worden sind also dass der
ausstieg aus der kohle der stopp der
entwaldung bis 2030 wie beurteilen sie
das und was hat das mit nachhaltig
wirtschaften zu tun sind das erste
schritte oder weichenstellungen
ja natürlich beurteile ich das als
schritt in die richtige richtung wobei
man ja ehrlicherweise sagen muss dass
viele der staaten die sich jetzt noch
mal committed haben aus der kohle
auszusteigen haben das vorher auch schon
getan insofern wird da in der tat
sozusagen ein bisschen aufgebauscht das
sind also schritte in die richtige
richtung die reichen nicht und vor allem
darauf zielte ja auch ihre frage ab die
haben in meinen augen noch viel zu wenig
mit nachhaltigen wirtschaften zu tun wir
werden das problem
nicht in den griff bekommen ohne eine
lösung zu finden für die großen
unternehmen wir sehen dass wenn wir das
global historisch anschauen nur 90
unternehmen seit beginn der
industrialisierung für zwei drittel der
treibhausgasemissionen der anthropogen
zuständig sind ob wir es mögen oder
nicht
irgendwas muss mit diesen akteuren
geschehen wir müssen uns mit denen
auseinander setzen wir müssen für die
andere anreize setzen sonst werden wir
das problem nicht in den griff bekommen
aber was wären denn solche anreize
zum beispiel und das hat mich immer
gewundert im bundestagswahlkampf dass
das so wenig eine rolle gespielt hat
eine große ökologisch soziale
steuerreform ein deutlich höherer co2
preis das ist natürlich ein ganz ganz
wichtiger anreiz wir haben ja auch ein
co2 preis ich bin der letzte der da
sozusagen argumentieren möchte dass es
gar nicht aber das muss
schneller gehen und natürlich brauchen
wir einen höheren co2 preis und auch
nicht nur in deutschland ein co2 preis
genau das wäre eine frage gewesen zum
einen deutschland da muss schon einiges
passieren aber auch im ausland china
russland sind auch große emittenten
nehmen uns wie kann man die darauf
verpflichten die sind ja gar nicht erst
mit zu mir zu hohen repräsentanten mit
regierungsvertretern bei der konferenz
gewesen also wie kann man in china und
russland dazu bringen mehr für für
klimaneutralität zu tun
william nordhaus seines zeichens
wirtschaftsnobelpreisträger hat er einen
sehr interessanten vorschlag gemacht
nämlich den vorschlag eines so genannten
kleinen clubs also eines klima clubs in
dem sich staaten zusammen tun die sich
darauf einigen einen co2 preis einer
gewissen höhe einzuführen und zu sagen
wer nicht mitmacht bei diesem klima club
der muss empfindliche zähne zahlen wenn
man in länder dieses klima clubs
importieren möchte und das ist natürlich
spreche viel über anreize das wäre dann
ein starker anreiz für länder wie die
die sie zitiert haben gerade für china
die natürlich unglaublich viel in die eu
oder nach nordamerika importieren auch
einen sehr hohen co2 preis einzuführen
jetzt haben wir einen kommentar von
youtube
nämlich dass durch staatliche
subventionen wie es sie heute gibt im
erneuerbaren sektor ein zombie
geschaffen wurde die meinung von max
power da der user name max power und der
diese zombie würde noch ein paar jahre
an uns kleben was halten sie von
subventionen und wie soll man damit
umgehen
ja wir müssen glaube ich eher schauen
dass wir das subventionieren wovon wir
mehr haben wollen und aufhören das zu
subventionieren wovon wir weniger haben
wollen und das zu besteuern von dem wir
eigentlich mehr haben wollen also ich
glaube dass es schon gut ist dass es
steuern gibt auf co2 wenn co2 und
steuern auf methan wenn das ganz
wichtige verursacher sind von
klimawandel und wir müssen ja aber
alternativen anbieten wir sehen ja auch
ich würde eher argumentieren dass die
entwicklung der erneuerbaren energien in
deutschland in den anderen ländern eine
erfolgsgeschichte ist und die wurde auch
durch subventionen erreicht da sind ja
auch viele arbeitsplätze entstanden da
haben wir also geschafft viele synergien
zu schaffen insofern sehe ich die
erneuerbaren energien ehrlich gesagt
nicht als zombie und die ja diese diese
meinung haben wir ja auch immer wieder
und der ausbau geht weiter und die
arbeitsplätze gibt es zu großen teilen
immer noch also da bin ich weniger
skeptisch
wenn wir zum beispiel auf einen punkt
schauen der sehr viele von uns betrifft
die noch mit autos unterwegs sind und
tanken müssen
die benzinpreise steigen
was bedeutet jetzt diese situation für
uns alle also müssen wir alle anfangen
auf dinge zu verzichten ich hab das auto
abgeschafft ich habe also kann er aber
andere sachen nicht sind trotzdem noch
wie früher ich esse immer noch fleisch
auch wenn es bio fleisch ist aber was
bedeutet dieser dieser klimawandel
letzten was bedeutet das jetzt für jeden
von uns jede von uns im einzelnen
verzicht
ja ist ja eine spannende frage ich
könnte zurückfragen war dass ein
verzicht auf ihr auto zu verzichten
es gibt ganz viele komponenten wo wir
keinen verzicht haben ob der strom den
ich beziehe der aus der steckdose kommt
aus erneuerbaren kommt oder aus kohle
das merke ich nicht das kann mir kein
mensch erzählen dass das ein verzicht
ist ich habe auch schon erwähnt dass da
viele arbeitsplätze entstanden sind ich
glaube bei vielen ist es auch einfach
eine umstellung wenn sie sagen sie haben
ihr auto abgeschafft ja dann ist das
bestimmt am anfang eine umstellung
gewesen wenn sie mehr mit dem fahrrad
oder mit der bahn fahren ob es ein
echter verzicht ist glaube ich nicht
dass nur umgewöhnung die macht auch
nicht immer spaß ich möchte das ganze
aber auch nicht kleinreden es gibt auch
komponenten die mit negativen wirkungen
einhergehen die mit verzicht einhergehen
es hilft auch um sozusagen ein bild zu
machen dem kohlekumpel nicht und
vielleicht auf dem schweinemastbetrieb
nicht wenn dort arbeitsplätze zu
verführt verloren gehen wenn in
erneuerbaren energien wenn in
digitalisierung für nachhaltige
entwicklung neuer arbeitsplätze
entstehen also ich möchte das nicht
kleinreden aber es gibt nicht nur
verzicht sondern es gibt auch
synergien und da wo wir wirklich eine
soziale schieflage haben natürlich muss
dagegen gesteuert werden und das ist ja
auch möglich die einnahmen die man
generiert über den zu höheren co2 preis
über eine sozial ökologische
steuerreform die dann gezielt für die zu
nutzen die durch höhere kosten für
benzin für energie et cetera wirklich
probleme haben
jetzt haben wir noch eine frage eines
users auf youtube erfragt jonas vollmer
wir fördern e autos warum kann man nicht
auch e bikes fördern um die leute
anzuspornen weniger auto zu fahren was
halten sie davon
die müssen ja auch aufgeladen werden die
batterien
ja das stimmt das kann man machen ich
glaube dass wir darüber diskutieren
können ich glaube aber auch wir müssen
jetzt wirklich schauen dass wir über die
großen über die grundsätzlichen fragen
sprechen wir werden ehrlich gesagt auch
den klimawandel nicht über eine
subvention von e bikes in den griff
bekommen sondern wir brauchen dafür
handfeste maßnahmen die sehr allgemein
eben auch die art unseres wirtschaftens
nicht nur nicht nur unseren
individuellen
unser individuelles zeit verändern ich
glaube dass ich ich würde auf die
subvention von e bikes verzichten wenn
ich dafür einen
relevanten co2 preis auf globaler ebene
hätte das ist das wo ich glaube müssen
wir jetzt die energie reinstecken dass
das erreicht werden kann jetzt hat die
hilfsorganisation oxfam hat jetzt eine
studie vorgelegt wonach der anteil der
reichen menschen oder wonach die reichen
menschen zu den treibern der
erderwärmung gehören also das
wohlhabendste prozent der
weltbevölkerung wird aller voraussicht
nach 2030 16 prozent des co2 ausstoßes
verursachen mit mega yachten mit
privatjet also man spricht hier von also
extrem spricht hier von den superreichen
und diese emissionen wären damit dreimal
falsch 30 mal so hoch wie für die
einhaltung des 1,5 grad zieles
verträglich wäre
wie muss man damit umgehen und was muss
man mit den superreichen anstellen oder
wie muss man die behandeln aus ihrer
sicht
erst mal ist das ja eine ganz ganz
spannende information und sie hatten
auch eine sendung dazu die ich mit
großem interesse verfolgt habe es gibt
der unzählige studien zu ja die höhe des
treibhausgasausstoßes die an personen
verursacht die korreliert mit dem
einkommen was heißt das denn eigentlich
das heißt dass diese ganze rhetorik dass
wenn wir co2-emission teurer machen dass
das zu einer umverteilung von unten nach
oben führt dass das eine mehr ist wenn
wir sehen dass superreiche wie sie die
genannt haben vor allem stark
co2-emissionen verursachen heißt das ja
auch dass wenn wir das besteuern dass
diese steuer vor allem superreiche
treffen würde für die es vielleicht
verkraftbar ist und wo ist doch eine
gute idee ist dass menschen die sehr
viel geld haben für die probleme die sie
verursachen auch bezahlen müssen
insofern ist das glaube ich erst mal
eine ganz ganz wichtige erkenntnis eine
co2 steuer das ist keine umverteilung
von unten nach oben sondern wenn wir die
für soziale zwecke nutzen dann ist es
eine umverteilung von oben nach unten
jetzt muss ich natürlich fragen weil
auch die koalitionsgespräche zu einer
möglichen ampelkoalition laufen und die
vermögenssteuer also das gruseln
gespenst für viele da irgendwie auch
immer durch die diskussionen war but was
halten sie denn davon von so einer
vermögenssteuer oder vermögensabgabe das
war ja auch im gespräch
ich glaube das ist sehr sinnvoll wäre
wenn wir entweder eine vermögenssteuer
oder eine vermögensabgabe oder eine
substanzielle erhöhung der
erbschaftsteuer hätten auch um klima
investitionen zu zu finanzieren aber mit
verlaub das ist ein bisschen eine andere
diskussion würde ich sagen dann kommen
wir auch eine gesellschaftliche
diskussion wie viel ausmaß an
ungleichheit wollen wir tolerieren ich
hätte eine sehr klare meinung zu aber
das hat nicht nur was mit dem
klimawandel zu tun ich glaube wenn wir
schauen wie wir die soziale schieflage
die entstehen kann durch höhere
benzinpreise durch höhere energiekosten
wie wir die in den griff bekommen wollen
dann können solche maßnahmen helfen ich
glaube wir müssen dann aber vor allem
aufhören immer mit der gießkanne zu
verteilen ja die pendlerpauschale wird
immer ganz ganz viel diskutiert und
immer anfällen festgemacht bei leuten
die ein sehr geringes einkommen haben
nun habe ich viele kolleginnen und
kollegen
professorinnen beispielsweise die in
hamburg wohnen und in lüneburg arbeiten
ist es wirklich notwendig dass wir die
pendlerpauschale dann für für eine
professorin aus hamburg die nach
lüneburg pendelt aufrechterhalten ich
glaube nicht wir müssen davon dem
gießkannenprinzip wegkommen wenn es für
sozial schwachen milieus probleme gibt
dadurch dass die energiekosten steigen
dadurch dass pendler kosten steigen dann
müssen wir hier gezielt helfen aber das
spricht in meinen augen überhaupt nicht
dafür dass auch sehr wohl verdiente
menschen dann eine eine pendlerpauschale
bekommen
das wäre sozusagen meine letzte frage
gewesen sind die sozialen kosten
aufzufangen wie kann man das aufwand
haben sie da konkret vorschläge
vielleicht erarbeitet schon oder oder
arbeiten sie an solchen vorschlägen wie
das konkret umgesetzt werden kann für
die leute die da täglich tatsächlich
darunter leiden
ja da gibt es ja unterschiedliche
vorschläge ob wir das ein klima geld
nennen oder ob wir das ein öko
bürgergeld mehr das ist mir dann relativ
egal ich glaube dass es in der tat
wichtig ist dass solche zahlungen
gezielt fließen ja es brauchen nicht
alle menschen ein klima geld sondern
lassen sie uns lieber gucken dass das
die menschen erreicht die vor allem
betroffen sind und die vor allem
probleme haben durch die gestiegenen
energiepreise durch vielleicht höhere
kosten für das pendeln das wäre mein
ganz konkreter vorschlag den ich nur
wiederholen kann lassen sie uns die
diskussion nicht so pauschal führen
brauchen wir die pendlerpauschale ja
oder nein vielleicht brauchen wir sie
einfach nur für einen sehr kleinen teil
der bevölkerung bekommt ihn für einen
sehr großen teil abschaffen brauchen wir
ein klima geld für alle das dann sehr
gering ist oder brauchen wir vielleicht
mehr unterstützung für sozial schwache
oder für in einer höheren dimensionen da
glaube ich müssen wir von diesen
gießkannenprinzip wegkommen
vielen dank herr professor hörisch für
diese antworten und ideen wir werden uns
zusammen noch anschauen wie der gipfel
in glasgow weitergeht und wie die
und was zum klimaschutz alles getan
werden wird auch im hinblick auf die
verhandlungen zu einer ampel-koalition
bis ende november oder dezember das wird
man sehen erst mal einen herzlichen dank
dass die zeit gefunden haben für unsere
fragen und die fragen der user
dankeschön und
das war es von uns vom live stream wir
haben einen letzten kommentar der gesagt
hat von facebook der
peter schletter ohne klima keine
wirtschaft das ist vielleicht gar kein
schlechter schlusspunkt und vielen dank
für eure fragen eure kommentare
macht's gut